these were the CEOs of today's five
biggest banks in the U.S in 2006. this
is that group in 2011. in 2016 and in
2021 you'll notice one face remained the
same this man JPMorgan Chase CEO Jamie
dimon he is the bank the bank is him in
some ways over his tenure Diamond has
become the go-to voice for banks we need
healthy big Banks we're the best banking
system in the world here's how Diamond's
strategy for managing risk has made him
the most powerful player in the industry
and how he's used that position to steer
the entire banking World Diamond built
his reputation over a career that
stretches back decades he has shaped how
the big Banks think about what is safe
and what isn't safe you can look around
and see that his lieutenants and former
Executives run a whole bunch of other
Banks and they all were schooled at how
to run a bank by Jamie dimon he's not a
reckless Banker I think he understands
to take risks to make money but you also
need to understand the risk and manage
the risk the center of diamonds risk
management strategy is a concept he
calls The Fortress balance sheet I
always thought you should have a
fortunate balance sheet in this business
and maybe some of yours because bad
things happen the idea is to build up a
cushion of assets and capital to protect
consumers deposits if the bank gets hit
by unexpected shock waves and most banks
will build the moat and build up their
walls and say we're protected but what
Jamie Diamond says is okay but those
walls might be made of like paper mache
so on top of that wall that all the
other banks have we're going to add a
higher wall and then we're going to add
some turrets up here and then we're
gonna add some people walking around all
the time making sure that everything is
safe all the way down is it fair to say
that JP Morgan could have losses of a
half a trillion dollars or a trillion
dollars not unless this Earth is hit by
a moon
okay he doesn't care about this
quarter's results he doesn't care about
next year's results he cares about
making sure the bank is safe partly he's
he gets to say that because he still
makes a ton of money on everything he
does
um but uh it's worked that strategy
helped JPMorgan Chase and Diamond emerge
from the 2008 financial crisis
relatively unscathed and even in a
position to assist the government we
were called upon to take action to help
stabilize the system in the aftermath
the bank put up big bids to acquire two
failing financial institutions from the
government bear Stearns and Washington
Mutual so he made some smart
Acquisitions that were beneficial to him
and beneficial to the government at the
time Sheila bear was the head of the
FDIC she orchestrated bids for
Washington Mutual the largest bank to
fail in U.S history we were having a
hard time getting bitters in a lot of
banks just didn't want to touch it so he
did not withstand the fact we were
running a competitive process he still
came in and bid thank goodness and as I
said as I suspected he would he did win
the bid by a pretty pretty large margin
even with debts incurred and lawsuits
following from those purchases the moves
helped Chase grow to be the largest bank
by deposits by 2011. he's going to look
at something like Washington Mutual and
say that's going to give us more
deposits and more customers we're
getting in at a super cheap price the
government's supposed to share the
losses this is a risk that is worth
taking the WAMU put us into California
where we really were in Florida we had
very small presence Washington State JP
Morgan grew even larger in May after it
bought First Republic ClickBank the
second largest bank to fail in U.S
history but this also raised concern
that the bank was too big to fail
meaning that if it were to collapse it
would have a devastating impact on the
economy are you too big to fail
I don't know what that word means
anymore JPMorgan Chase does benefit from
the perception of being too big to fail
I know they don't like to hear that they
think they're very well run and they are
a great bank but I'm sorry that they get
a benefit nobody thinks even if JPMorgan
Chase got into trouble nobody thinks
it would ever be closed but Diamond has
made missteps in the past in 2012 the
bank lost more than six billion dollars
after an employee made a series of risky
bets this transaction that you said
morphed what it did what did it morph
into Russian Roulette and morphed into
something I can't justify that was just
too risky for our company he does impose
accountability in the context of risk
that could be one of your best risk
management tools just to make sure you
know tell your people go out and take
some risks make some money understand
the risk manage the risk stay within our
risk appetite and understand you know if
you take stupid risk you're going to be
accountable I said I always don't put me
on the pedestal just just to stop that
companies make mistakes and CEOs make
mistakes
wild diamonds management style has
helped the bank grow even larger than
its competitors it's also expanded his
role in the industry if you're the
treasury secretary and there's something
broken in the banking industry Jamie
dime is your first call treasury
secretary Janet Yellen called Diamond to
kick-start First Republic's initial
rescue effort it bought the bank time it
did seem to help the crisis and really
other CEOs and other banks have been
like it was it was Jamie and over the
years Diamond has become the go-to voice
for banks in Washington members of the
committee I appreciate the opportunity
to talk about JPMorgan Chase the role of
America's largest banks as a Force for
good for the country its citizens and
the global economy when they all go to
testify pretty much every year in front
of Congress the other CEOs are like
let's let Jamie answer the questions
we'll we'll let him be the guy out front
and part of that's because like he's
built this reputation and he's less
worried about losing his job or getting
Regulators mad at him I think it would
put smaller banks in a position that
when a crisis hits they will actually
have to stop lending because putting up
those reserves would be too much at
precisely the wrong time so I do things
it becomes an issue for you all to to
reconsider and diamond is known to be
outspoken in public statements too
Bitcoin itself is a is a hyped up fraud
it's all
you ask me I'll tell you my opinion is
that's not a JPMorgan opinion stuff like
that but he is the same person privately
and publicly like he'll curse he'll
he'll get excited about things he'll
dismiss other things like he is Jamie a
spokesperson for JPMorgan Chase and
Jamie dimon declined to comment for this
video
after nearly two decades a top JPMorgan
Chase there have been questions about
who could fill his shoes when he decides
to move on he truly has no Hobbies from
what I can tell his even his friends are
like he doesn't do anything other than
run the bank but Diamond doesn't plan on
going anywhere soon I'm not gonna play
golf I love my country I love my company
I love my family I have I'm going to do
something I can't do this forever I know
that
but my intensity is the same a normal
person might say it's time to hang out
the shoes but Jamie Diamond is not
necessarily a normal person
thank you